if you want to know how jaws almost
killed the entire town of amity
including the deaths that were taken out
of the movie then stick around to the
end of this video
jaws is the beast from the sea that
rarely surfaced in his own movie but
came out slightly more in the novel
oftentimes leaving a trail of blood and
flesh in his way he was the nightmare
laying siege physically and mentally to
the small town of amity and their
year-round residence jaws author peter
benchley stated that he could never
write jaws today or really even demonize
an animal since jaws is a shark we're
going to look at what makes him the
demon that benchley originally intended
so in today's episode we'll attempt to
analyze the shark's impact on amity
through a psychological one
to understand the full threat of the
shark's occupation we've got to start by
understanding the town
amity is one of the summer communities
on long island southern shore the
population of its year-round residents
is about one thousand
boosting to ten thousand in the summer
the summertime residents are important
for keeping amity a thriving community
during the winter since they mainly
consist of lawyers and bankers who are
looking to get away for 12 weeks there
is this logic that all of the full-time
residents follow where everyone does
what they can to maintain a good image
for the town
that way it always appears to be a
favorable place to spend the summers
this is done to produce a wealthy summer
season to get through the winter where
even after the best summers 3 of every
10 families go on relief due to this
understanding the police chief martin
brody and the editor of the local paper
harry meadows will filter
the news to ensure that amity appears
attractive to the summer people who
subscribe to the local paper
at the same time the understanding roots
out anyone who is potentially dishonest
in their work ethic a few years before
the novel two brothers came to amity to
start running a carpentry business and
originally earned a good reputation
after long-time residents discovered
their use of inferior parts while
charging for higher quality ones the
people of amd made sure that it was
impossible for them to run their
business
this unspoken agreement is stated to
root from a need to survive
meaning that one or two bad apples have
to be tossed out as quickly as possible
if not they could ruin the revenue for
the entire town
the amity understanding is a portrayal
of how local and traditional mindsets
function within modern limitations the
peaceful nature of the community is
interrupted when the shark appears in
their waters measuring in at about 20
feet long
four feet wide at the snout and an
estimated weight of five to six thousand
pounds
jaws is bigger than a large pickup truck
and this is slightly smaller than his
film counterpart bruce who measures up
to 25
feet jaws first emerges from the depths
around 1am on june 16th
nearly a whole month before the movie
he's initially attracted to amity's
beaches by the vibrations of a late
night swimmer
christine chrissy watkins starting by
making a wide circle around her the
water briefly surges up before settling
back down
being alerted to something she pauses
for a moment since she's already tired
and a bit uneasy she starts to hurry
back to the shore she initially believed
that some coral or driftwood had scraped
against her leg but when she went down
to reach for her foot she has to reach
higher and higher until her fingers
found the nub of her bone
streaming in panic she starts thrashing
for the shore taking his chance jaws
dives down before ramming into her from
below and tossing her out of the water
clamping his mouth around her torso he
slams back down into the water in a
shower of blood and scraps of flash
this seems to be the point that jaws
develops a craving for human flesh
instead of you know just seals and fish
and the sunday deal at long john
silver's
a normal shark might have spat her leg
out because people are too bony and
don't have the amount of fat content
that sharks typically prefer
typically when sharks do go for people
it's because they're starving or just
confuse the person for a seal
or you know the sunday deal at long john
rather than that
jaws becomes the monster of nightmares
by deciding the waters of amity are now
part of its home range
adding this stop to its migration route
probably means that it'll stick around
for anywhere from one to three months
in doing this he becomes the harbinger
of the resident's worst fears and the
revealer of their darkest secrets
jaws becomes known as an unforgiving
overlord as the gatekeeper of amity the
initial response from mayor vaughn and
meadows was to keep it quiet to ensure a
good summer revenue
despite chief brody's insistence to
close the beaches their logic to keep
them open was that the attack was
probably a one-time thing since sharks
don't usually stay in one place for that
long
chief brody originally objects arguing
with mayor vaughn that he has the
interest of public safety in mind
however he seems to be the only one for
closing the beaches
with his job threatened by the mayor he
concedes and allows the beaches to stay
open the offensive nature of vaughn's
position appears to be justified based
on the amity understanding
they still need the summer to go well
enough for the town to survive through
the winter
meanwhile chief brody's position
initially seems to come from his fear of
the ocean and any water that's deeper
than his shoulders in this sense jaws is
the physical embodiment of chief brody's
fear of the demons under the water the
next time jaws surfaces is on monday
june 20th when six-year-old alex kinser
goes on a swim in a small raft the raft
alex is on is small enough for him to
use it similarly to a boogie board or a
surfboard
he doesn't notice the current carrying
him further from the shore until he's
about 40 yards away with his legs
splashing in the water the shark hones
in on the movement it stirs jaws follows
the vibration until he's about 20 feet
away
then there's a brief moment where he
loses the signal passing directly under
alex as the boy takes a break it's not
until alex starts kicking again that
jaws locks in on the source of the
movement
he propels himself almost straight out
of the water knocking the child and the
raft into his mouth
now i tried doing this at the taco bell
drive-through by just sticking my head
out the window and flooring it but it
didn't go quite how i
imagined unlike my taco alex's death was
quick and
over before the boy could scream the
only part of him not swallowed was his
legs
as jaws flops back into the ocean alex's
father on shore notices the movement
when he goes to mrs cainter the
realization takes a moment to set in
together they go to the police station
to report the incident unfortunately for
amity two reporters from the new york
times and
newsday respectively happen to be at the
beach they both inhabit the police
station after the event trying to get
information to publish a story this is
one of the worst situations for amity if
the story got out their fourth of july
weekend would be a bust and potentially
force the town into a massive decline
over the winter with money already tight
in most households a poor summer could
lead to the townspeople buying cheaper
goods resulting in declining tax revenue
which would make it difficult to
effectively maintain public works like
gas and electricity the domino effect
could lead to long-time residents moving
out and turning amity into a ghost town
in the middle of this exchange another
cop named patrolman hendrix bursts
bersan frantically informing chief brody
of another attack
and this one would be too gruesome to
include in the movie
after the patrolman's outburst chief
brody is silently thankful that the
reporters failed to notice the slip of
hendricks's tongue with the word another
hendrix is the most up to speed on the
shark attacks aside from the chiefs so a
massive slip up like that could have
jeopardized the reputation of the town's
authorities
urging him to continue hendricks
describes how he went to the beach for
the first time in years and heard a
surfer scream as he was repeatedly
knocked down
he explained to chief brody that blood
was flying all over the place the fish
kept coming back and hitting him again
and again
hendricks had tried to go and help the
man reaching waist-deep water but by the
time he was able to grab the man's hand
his arm fell away from his shoulder this
type of attack pattern is generally used
by sharks for larger prey like elephant
seals which can fight back and do damage
to their skin
the idea is to stun the prey making them
easier to kill and consume we can only
imagine the shark felt somewhat
intimidated by the sheer size of the
man's surfboard since boards usually
range from six to seven feet long
this surfer incident on top of the
cancer boy causes chief brody to order
the immediate closure of all beaches to
ensure public
safety sounds all too familiar when
discussing the situation with mayor
vaughn the two decide to hunt down the
shark before it can do any further
damage
on tuesday june 24th the local fisherman
ben gardner was sent out on his boats to
look for jobs
chief brody spends an hour watching his
boats the flicka with binoculars until
hendricks shows up to see how things are
going
expressing his concern the chief decides
to head to the marina to borrow a boat
with hendricks
when they reach gardner's boat they
can't find any sign of him they look
around and discover that the radio is
still on and the boat is anchored in at
least 100 feet of water the only signs
of what could have happened were some
scraped paints and what could have been
a bite mark on the whole
noticing something in one of the
punctures the chief lifts hendricks over
the side when he's pulled back into the
boat hendricks reveals a two
inch wide shark tooth the only
conclusion they can come up with is that
jaws got a hold of vents somehow
it's a reasonable one too as there have
been documented instances of great white
sharks attacking fishing boats it's a
bit unclear why jaws would attack the
boat i mean it could be that it saw the
dropping anchor as a threat
or possibly that he smelled fish and was
curious about if he could eat the boat
or not when sharks are on the prowl for
food they usually take a bite first to
see if they like it and if it doesn't
taste
like something in their usual diet then
they usually just leave it but if this
impact knocked ben into the water
jaws might have just taken that as his
reward instead remember this particular
shark seems to have actually developed a
taste for humans
by now jaws knows a few things about the
waters around amity first is that
there's always food around even on the
boats and
people count as a tasty food source with
ben gardner's death we're introduced to
the ichthyologist matt hooper
basically hooper study sharks and
frequently dives with them he's
described as being clean-shaven
tanned lean and in his mid-20s so
basically nothing like the bearded
description in the film because
supposedly having a big beard like that
can get in the way while diving another
differing point in the film is that
chief brody has an immediate dislike
towards hooper while they're on good
terms on the screen their novel
depictions frequently get into arguments
over almost
everything in the wake of hooper's
arrival and ben's death hooper begins
using the flicka to patrol the waters
with the beaches still closed he's able
to test the water and study the marine
life in hopes of finding out why jaws is
there
unfortunately for hooper he doesn't run
into the shark after spending an entire
week studying the area so when he
attends the meeting of the selectmen
mayor vaughn and chief brody he confirms
that they should be clear to reopen the
beaches for the 4th of july weekend he
also notes that the water is getting too
warm for a great white to be there the
chief doesn't want anything reopened
claiming that they don't know if the
shark actually left or not despite his
initial feeling the selectmen and the
mayor point out that the town is dying
the past two weeks have had a major
impact on local businesses forcing many
to have sales just to scrape in a little
bit of profits with the beaches open for
the holiday weekend
chief brodie sets hendricks up on the
public beach hooper out in the flicka
and himself on the private beaches to
keep watch for any signs of the shark
on july 3rd the chief encountered a
family trespassing on the private
beaches
in their conversation he discovers that
amity is getting a reputation for having
a killer shark inhabiting the waters
the family came to the beach hoping to
get a glimpse and this was the exact
opposite of what amity wants to be known
for while having a man-eating shark will
keep a lot of tourist money away
there are some people who would travel
out of their way to see these
interesting creatures even if that means
risking their life
what why are you looking at me like that
however the town would end up nearly
completely abandoned before shark
spotting would become its main point of
interest the bad luck in amity doesn't
seem to run out all it takes to stir up
a sense of unease is for a young boy to
go swimming on a bet
and the shark would not be brody's only
worry with a news reporter also prowling
the scene of this summertime getaway
brody keeps an eye out for the boy as he
goes out it doesn't take long for hooper
to see something in the water and
quickly turn the boat around
radioing hooper the chief tells him
about the boy so that he can move the
boat closer what they don't know is that
jaws was hanging around underneath the
flicka for most of the day
the change in the boat's motor brings
the shark to life causing it to follow
the boat towards shallower water and
towards the boy chief brodie moves into
the water a bit getting knocked back by
a wave as the boy reaches chest deep
water and tries moving further towards
the shore the fin of the shark appears
out of the water behind him
between the chief and the shark the boy
moves a little bit faster because he
knows something is wrong
in a stroke of luck chief brody gets the
boy first and jaws retreats deeper into
the water while this scene is tense it
does display the natural limitations of
the shark since he has to continuously
move forward in order to breathe he has
to avoid accidentally beaching himself
over
a mouthful of food so the shallower
areas were essentially off limits
forced to close the beaches again amity
has to come up with another solution in
a last-ditch effort they call in former
war veteran turned shark hunter named
sam
quint a man who takes the cliche swears
like a sailor to the extreme
i'd love for him to meet our cab driver
from it with a new ally came a new boat
and even with a bigger boat
jaws was unafraid to back down from a
challenge you're gonna need a bigger
boat
on quinn's boat orca they managed to
encounter jaws a total of three times
the first time is only a brief passing
the second time hooper hops into his
shark cage to see jaws underwater and
take some photos when he goes in he
takes an underwater weapon in case jaws
gets too close
on the initial pass jaws swims close
enough to the cage for hooper to run his
hand along the side
the interaction is peaceful until the
sounds of quint firing shots into the
water disturb the scene
once this happened jaws swims out a bit
before ramming himself into the cage
he manages to pry the bars apart with
his continued ramming the same technique
used against elephant seals and more
dangerous prey it seems that jaws didn't
truly feel threatened until the shots
were fired at him
the disturbance agitated him to some
degree and he associated it with a
strange cage floating nearby
the hooper in the novel isn't as
fortunate as his film counterpart
before he's able to use the weapon the
shark bites down on his torso in a
display of
graphic details jaws jumps out of the
water hooper's legs hanging out of one
side of his mouth and his head and arms
out the other
i guess mrs john never taught her son
any proper manners at the dinner table
with hooper dead quintet declares that
this hunt is no longer a matter of money
though he never speaks the reason it
seems clear that he's developed a
burning desire to kill it
even if he has to do it alone their
final encounter with jaws turns into a
storied hunt that the novel has led up
to
once they get to a specific area closer
to the shore jaws surfaces as if waiting
for them within a half hour quinton
brady managed to hook three harpoons
into him one by his fin another near his
stomach and one in the head
just above the right eye during this
jaws attempts to sink their boat by
ramming into it even taking a bite to
shake the boat
eventually jaws resorts to trying to
swim away for nearly three hours
dragging the vessel with him as he goes
when the barrels stop moving quince
takes them in close to lasso jaws tail
and attempt to hoist him up on the winch
but jaws turns in a last-ditch effort to
escape and crashes onto the deck and the
impact is enough to start sinking the
boat in a mad fit of fury quince takes
the harpoon and stabs the shark in the
gut
deep enough for blood to cover his
entire hand when jaws rolls back into
the water quint's leg gets caught in the
rope tethered to the harpoon and he's
pulled overboard
jaws is simply trying to get back into
the water just in order to breathe but
it causes quince to end up drowning from
his own slip up pretty brutal way to go
but not as much as the movie though roll
that [ __ ]
luckily for chief brody he doesn't need
a gun or an oxygen tank to save himself
in the end
jaws is merely a mortal shark and dies
from his injuries just before getting
the chance to take a bite out of brody
the last we see of jaws is him sinking
back towards the depths of the ocean
in the end jaws terrorized the people of
amity and their summer visitors for
nearly an entire month the six victims
taken were not the only way that the
creature wrecked havoc on citizens
though it potentially ruined the entire
summer season economy
making the upcoming winter more
difficult while the film shows jaws as a
ruthless killer the novel reveals a more
realistic depiction of a shark with some
tendencies that we can analyze and
understand and others that can still not
be explained hopefully this analysis
helps add a layer of reality behind the
ocean dwelling terror that is jaws and
by the way let me know what other
creatures you'd like to see covered here
on horror history or what franchise
you'd like to see me take on remember to
subscribe to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring the death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one assuming
we both survive